Hello Freak bitches.
Do you get blood work done?
Um,
I haven't,
I,
I have uh,
I've got prescription to like measure
like all,
like my nutrient levels and I've just
been too lazy to go get it done.
That's ridiculous though.
You're a professional at the highest
level of the game and I'm,
I'm an idiot.
I don't know,
I just,
I'm a procrastinator with it because you
know,
one day I'll,
I'll feel like crappy and I'll be
talking to my osteopath.
It'd be like go get these blood work
done,
see what your deficiencies are.
So we will get a prescription and I'll
never go do it.
I'm scared of needles.
It's a big thing.
You're scared of needles.
Get the fuck Outta here.
I pass out.
I'm not joking.
I'm not scared to fight in a cage many
times doing ivs or stuff like that.
Yeah man,
I hate it.
I sold like when you're rehydrating like
when they give you an ivy,
you pass out and faint and then I will
wake up and everyone's looking at almost
attacked for us and a couple of guys
because I woke up and didn't know where
it was and I was just like,
that's
sucks.
I used to date this girl who couldn't
even watch someone get a needle in a
movie.
She would black out.
Yeah.
If I think about it too hard then I'll
let get my stomach will like,
that's so weird.
Yeah.
But that's the only logical.
I don't understand what that is and it
only happened like it only started
happening like four or five years ago.
Reward like blood because you have to
get blood work done for the fights,
right.
Past your HIV and all that stuff.
And before I would just be like,
yeah,
and it's done.
Walk away now.
Then all of a sudden out of nowhere,
every time I see a needle coming my way,
I see my face will get white and for no
reason that's so strange.
So I have to like,
get on my phone like this,
I have to lay down like it's a whole
host of look away and look.
Oh yeah.
Distract myself.
Wow.
Even talking about right now,
like,
get like a.
that's so strange.
I mean it was,
it would make more sense.
It was something you always had.
Yeah.
It's so weird.
Like my ex girlfriend,
her dad had it and she said that her dad
one time,
um,
her brother got like a severe sunburn
and the blisters all over him and the
Dad saw it and the dad fainted.
And what's crazy is that dad was a
fucking doctor.
He was,
he was,
he was a dentist.
So I'm like,
how the fuck is this guy like me?
Obviously you must deal with some fucked
up shit and gory things.
Stills in dentistry too weird.
He,
I guess he was okay with needles,
but he would see certain things like he
saw his son with blisters from
listers
because you know,
like from,
from the sun,
from sunburn.
And he apparently had a really bad
sunburn.
It's weird.
It's fucking weird,
right?
Yeah,
it's in her family.
I guess,
but it's weird that you acquired it.
That's virtually nowhere.
It was just like one,
it was,
I was doing blood work for uh,
a fight and I was at the hospital and
that was just like everyday and then I
passed out and ever since then it
happens.
So I have to be really careful.
Uh,
but this guy goes around and just
records people.
Regular people walks up to you,
records you and puts it online and
whatever.
He edits it together and puts it on
Youtube.
What else?
Kinda fucked up.
Fucked up.
That's very fucked up is he agreed.
I wouldn't know who.
We know who the guy is,
no idea.
So he doesn't put himself on ever fuck
that guy.
So he walks up to people and gets a
various responses.
Some people like he walks up to chew all
this stuff.
Got pulled off youtube,
but it's on La live leak now.
He walks up to two mormons,
the ones that go door to door and
they're super polite.
They're like,
whoa.
oh,
you're recording us.
Whatever.
They have a nice conversation and they
walk off.
But then other people,
they're trying to knock them out,
but I think it's so.
It's so interesting how
the camera in and of itself almost has
this social view of of like like a
weapon in a way.
It's like you're pointing that thing at
me because you're attempting to take.
The person's not doing anything wrong by
pointing the thing.
No,
no,
no.
I mean the person that's getting
recorded,
you're not doing anything wrong.
Why does it make us feel so
uncomfortable?
You're opening up a door for a bunch of
other people to enter into your life.
If you take a guy,
I'll got back.
I took a camera on you.
I don't know you.
I find you take a camera and then I put
it on the youtube channel that has a
million subscribers like yours does.
Well,
no,
no.
Let's say the person doesn't know that
when they're being recorded.
Okay.
That right?
Like if you're out in the street,
probably doesn't count for you because
somebody might know who you are and what
in that case,
but if you're a regular everyday person
and someone walks up to you with their
smartphone and they're just a few feet
away from you,
recording you that like that's what he's
doing.
He's not announcing that it's going to
be on youtube,
but people's reactions are intense.
Shouldn't be phone still is fun and kick
him in the Dick.
Fuck that.
But maybe he wins.
He wins that way.
He wins the housing when.
Because I stole his phone.
No,
because that's because that's a way
better clip.
If you don't get it,
if you don't get that phone,
oh,
I'll get his phone,
get his phone.
Well,
whatever you may,
you may be more gifted than others who
fail in his clips to get it from him.
Like a sprinter.
While he's,
he,
he starts to get he.
He moves away at the right time.
This guy's crazy.
He interrupts like,
uh,
he,
he.
There are cases where he walks behind
the cash register at Mcdonald's and
starts recording people that are making
burgers and they're just like,
what the fuck?
Or in certain cases,
like he don't,
he walks,
he walks into like a,
um,
a card game that's going on private card
game and he's recording it like he takes
risks to,
to get that footage.
But I agree with you.
Fuck that guy.
But at the same time,
I think it sort of unveils something
about humanity and how we're not
completely ready for a fully recorded
future.